Channing Tatum says he'll do everything
in his power to get Tom Hanks in the
splash remake still so you know how
Marion
ET was with the 36-year old actor on the
red carpet of the 22nd annual
fulfillment fun gala at universal
studios in los angeles on wednesday
where he revealed he and actress
julianne Bell had kicked around the idea
of doing a remake of the 1984 disney
film for years before it came to
fruition and when it finally did they
didn't let the original star Tom Hanks
in on it we were too afraid to like you
know we were so kind of it was bit of a
shot in the dark but now that the film
has been greenlit by disney channel says
he'll be doing the most to get a minute
I will be washing Tom's car doing
everything I can possibly do to get him
in that movie
Channing also opened up about the
pressure he and wife jenna dewan field
when it comes to their three-year-old
daughter Everly's education I think for
my daughter you know nowadays especially
in Los Angeles is always pressure even
not even in elementary school yet and
there's like what school she and what's
what's she doing what's the plan with
the past and I might have no idea like i
just wanted to enjoy going to school I
just wanted to like want to go and
that's and that's it